welcome back rocky caught up with a
local real estate guru
who is all about faith empowerment and
luxury
nasheed welcome to las vegas now ah
thank you for having me
of course a whole lot of beauty and
brains on this zoom call right now i
can't wait to talk to you about all of
these awards i see behind you and i
understand you won
best of las vegas 2020 yes i
won the gold best of las vegas 2020
and i was actually really shocked um
i was up against a lot of
you know great brokers in town luxury
brokers and brokerages
and i kind of didn't even want to try
but then i'm like you know
i need to try i need to go for it
absolutely deserving i understand you
have a license
in nevada and california so just tell us
a little bit about your business and
what you do
for all of us here yeah so i've been
doing real estate in vegas for 15 years
since
2006. i recently
opened my brokerage in southern
california and i have some
luxury listings there and clients there
and you know it just made sense since we
have
so many people from california right now
moving
here so it's like you know you can sell
their property there work with them here
as a buyer
so it's worked throughout really well
thankfully and
what i love most about you know all of
your success is that you give back
to the community as well let's talk
about what you donate um
through your commission so it's really
important for me to after every closing
to donate a percentage of my commissions
to different foundations right now i'm
associated with
nevada childhood cancer foundation uh so
after every closing i give them a
portion
and also my test rescue she rescues
dogs so i just kids and dogs you know
now let's talk about your clientele who
who do you help
here in las vegas uh so
you know i've been doing this 15 years
so i'm
a little bit more specific with who i
choose to take on
i love to work you know with good people
with integrity
and then you know luxury properties or
investors that buy in bowl
i'm looking at your place right now
which is very luxurious and beautiful
what does las vegas have to offer these
days
vegas still offers you know that big
city life that excitement and properties
are still
not as expensive as other big cities you
know like la new york chicago
yes but yeah and you still have like a
great fun city
but the prices are going up it's getting
there just because inventory is so low
you love to empower women through your
business as well let's talk about that
i feel like i have a story and i love to
share my story
to be able to you know let women know
that
you too can also have you know the
success you want
the love life you want you can have
everything that you want
you just have to you know it just goes
so much deeper you have to have like a
certain level of faith
integrity work on yourself and never
give up never settle for less and you
really can have
whatever you dream of give mushid a call
at 702-769-6274
or visit masheed.com for more
las vegas now